we're on problem where are we problem 49
49 and it says what is the square root
of seven plus the square root of seven
and all of that squared so this is
really just a little bit of
simplification so if I have two of
something in this case I have 2 square
roots of 7 if I add them together I get
two of it so I get 2 square roots of 7
and I'm squaring that and 2 square roots
of 7 squared that's equal to 2 squared
times the square root of 7 squared all
right that's just your exponent
properties so that is equal to 4 times
what's the square root of 7 squared well
it's just 7 right so it's 4 times 7
which is equal to 28 which is choice C
next problem 50 in a certain population
there are 3 times as many people age 21
or under there are people over 21 okay
so let's say that X is equal to under 21
under and Y is equal to over 21 so in a
certain population there are 3 times as
many people aged under age 21 or under
21 or under so X is equal to as there
are people over 21 so there's a number
of people under 21 and there are three
times as many as there are over 21 the
ratio of those 21 are under 2 the popul
population is so they want to know the
ratio of X under 21 or 21 or under 2 the
total population not just to the over
right not just to the over 21 population
so what's the total population
well that's everyone right X plus y is
equal to total so what they want is the
ratio of X to X plus y so they want the
ratio of X to X plus y and then we could
do how to notice
let's do a little bit of simple
substitution we know X is equal to 3y so
let's substitute that into this
this is the ratio they're trying to
figure out ratio of 21 or under to the
total population so X is equal to 3y
over 3y plus y I just did that because
like wow if we do that then it looks
like we could be able to cancel out all
the Y's so we get 3y over what what's 3y
plus another Y what's 4y and Y's cancel
out and you get 3/4 and that is choice E
3 2 4 next question
51 51 and actually you know you didn't
even have to do it algebraically if you
just think about question 50 you could
have just played with numbers you can
say okay there are three times as many
people aged 21 or under as there are
people over 21 so you say okay if
there's one person over 21 there'd be
three people under 21 and there'd be a
total of four people so it'd be three to
four but anyway
either way didn't take us too long so
they've drawn a figure here let me draw
it as well so they have two lines that
intersect something like that and they
say that this angle right here is 3 x
degrees this angle is y plus 30 degrees
and they say this angle is 2x degrees
and they say the figure above the value
of y is what well that you could there's
a bunch of ways you can do it the way it
pops out to me is we could figure out X
because we know that this angle Plus
this angle is equal to 180 degrees
because they are supplementary and they
go all the way halfway around the circle
so we know that if we add 3x plus 2x
that should equal 180 degrees or 5x is
equal to 180 or that X is equal to what
30 30 let's see 30 times 5 is 150 then
you have 30 left over so it's 36 degrees
right 36 times 5 is yep 180 and now we
know if X is 36 degrees what is this
angle well this angle is going to be 72
degrees it's 2 times X 72 degrees and
then this angle in this angle or the
opposite angles and you could do the
angle game module on Khan Academy if
that doesn't ring a bell
but that should ring a bell from John
great and there's another way you can do
it you could say that this angle that
this angle Plus this angle have to equal
180
either way you could do it either way
but the easiest way is to say that this
angle and this angle are equal because
they're opposite angles so we know that
Y plus 30 has to equal this angle equals
72 subtract 30 from both sides you get Y
is equal to 42 degrees which is choice E
next problem make it a different color
now 52 Kelly and Chris packed several
boxes with books if Chris packed 60% of
the total so Chris Chris packed 60% of
total Chris packed 60% of the total
number of boxes what was the ratio of
the number of boxes
Kelly packed to the number of boxes
Chris packed so they want to know the
ratio of Kelly to Chris right
well if Chris packed 60% of the total we
could say that you know
let's see be the number that Chris
packed so that'll be equal to 0.6 of the
total well then that means that Kelly
packed the rest of them right so I'm
assuming it's a it's a she Kelly would
have packed the remainder which is 40%
of the total Kelly would be 40% of the
total
so the ratio of the number that Chris
that what do they want to know what was
the ratio of the number of boxes Kelly
packed to the number of boxes Chris
packed so they want another issue of K
to see well K is 0.4 T and C is 0.6 t
T's cancelled out you get essentially is
4 over 6 which is 2/3 if you multiply
the top and bottom by 10 it becomes 4
over 6 so you get 2 to 3 and that is
choice that is choice E problem 53
fifty-three of the following which is
the closest approximation of fifty point
two times 0.49 over one ninety-nine
point eight so I haven't looked at the
choices yet but if I had to approximate
what this is I would say well that's the
same that's close to fifty right fifty
point two is really close to fifty times
0.49 is really close to 0.5 all of that
over one ninety-nine point eight is
really close to two hundred right so you
could view this as being equal to see 50
25 over two hundred and twenty-five over
two hundred they see 25 you could divide
the top and the bottom by 25 you get 1
over 25 goes into 100 four times within
208 times and that is one of our choices
so I'll go with that b18 problem 54 54
the average of 10 30 and 50 is okay so
they say the average of 10 so the
average is going to be 10 plus 30 plus
50 so the average of those three is that
divided by 3 so first well what is that
well it looks like it should be 30 right
because you get 60 plus 30 over 3 so
that's 90 so the average of 10 30 and 50
is 5 more so it equals 5 more then the
average of 20 the average of 20 40 and
one of the choices and X so to write
this we say okay so we figured out that
the average oh sorry the average here
isn't sorry I'm I've wrote this a little
bit let me redo this for you so let's
say the average of 10 30 and 50 and we
already figured out 10 plus 30 plus 50
if you average that divided by 3 you get
third you get 80 90 divided by 3 is
equal to 30 and you actually don't even
have to do the math you could have said
oh we'll have 30 in the middle 50
20 more than 30 2010 is 20 less than 30
so the average going to be 30 but this
didn't take you much time so the average
is 30 and they say that that is 5 more
than the average of 20 40 and another
number so 30 is equal to 5 plus the
average of those 3 numbers so the
average of those 3 numbers are 20 plus
40 plus x over 3 right so let's just
simplify this let's subtract 5 from both
sides you get 25 is equal to 20 plus 40
plus X over 3 if you multiply both sides
by 3 you get 75 is equal to what's 20
plus 40 plus 6 it equals 60 plus X and
then you subtract 60 from both sides you
get X is equal to 15 and that is choice
a and then almost have time so I'll see
you in the next video see you soon